l'hymne national ô noël
minuit chrétien à la page 22 je sais que
vous la maison sur skype ou ccao en
entier août des puits la fois
contiennent une oreille chanter page 22
vidic retiens
c'est leur sont la mer
[Applaudissements]
dieu
descendez jusqu'à nous
ou lui passé
la tache originelle
et d'un sens faire
arrêté
pour vous
monde entier
mais ça y est
[Musique]
en cela c'est de lui
tout va
non
e
à genoux
à temps
[Musique]
à des libéraux
c'est
tout
noël
voici
le
en tout
[Musique]
si
le
deux autres froid
que la lumière attentes
nourries de tous au berceau
quand votre foi
une étoile brillante
les conduisit
le chef de
ils ont le droit de le roi des rois
du thym
est puissant de jours
[Musique]
enfin
à
[Musique]
m